alors on n'en saura pas plus donc
concernant la candidature ou non de
mathieu colombani à montigny en tout cas
on poursuit avec tes économies la
chronique et cause ce soir bonsoir alice
et la chronique échos ce soir plusieurs
sujets ah ben oui tout à fait bonsoir à
tous alors on va commencer avec les
chiffres du chômage on avait parlé il ya
deux semaines alors on y revient pour
octobre 2012 en ile-de-france et dans
les yvelines on va le voir à l'écran en
détail en ile de france plus de 500 e
575000 un demandeur d'emploi de
catégorie a c'est à dire ceux n'ayant
pas travaillé le mois précédent et plus
de 55000 dans les yvelines sur une
population d'environ 1 million 400 mille
habitants alors on va s'intéresser à
l'évolution du chômage d'une part chez
les jeunes en ile-de-france ce chômage
représente 16,8 pour cent soit 0 1% de
hausse en un an à la même époque en
octobre 2011 dans les yvelines le
pourcentage de 19,2 pour cent une hausse
de 0 5% mon convoi
fo ne va pas très bien du côté des
jeunes les moins de 26 ans on va faire
un saut générationnel on arrive chez les
seniors avec les plus de 50 ans en
ile-de-france donc le taux de chômage de
21,6 % une augmentation de 1,3 pour cent
en un an et dans les yvelines ce taux a
aussi augmenté d'un pour cent puisqu'il
atteint 21,6 % également alors le
chômage qui touche tout le monde malgré
ça il ya des entreprises qui recrutent
toujours exactement voilà malgré ces
mauvais chiffres des secteurs peinent à
recruter en tête l'aide à domicile 1 qui
recrute énormément et puis la
restauration le directeur départemental
de pôle emploi va nous expliquer les
trois causes de ce phénomène on
l'écoutent en premier lieu des métiers
pour lesquels il y a des contraintes
particulières notamment liée à
l'amplitude horaire on va retrouver les
métiers par exemple de l'aide à domicile
où ce sont des plus tôt des emplois à
temps partiel relativement et disséminés
sur le territoire et pour lequel il est
parfois difficile de trouver la bonne
personne en proximité pour assurer deux
heures de ménage deux heures des
domiciles en proximité du besoin
on a aussi des métiers très technique
pour lequel il ya une
une difficulté une pénurie de personnes
formées sur le territoire ces
déformations relativement longue
en premier lieu on va retrouver dans ces
métiers les métiers de l'informatique
hélas en volumétrie assez importante sur
le territoire notamment sur la zone la
zone de saint quentin en yvelines où là
on a une volumétrie assez importante
troisième lieu sur trois une situation
de métier sur le client la diffuse de
recrutement on va retrouver des métiers
sur le cac tir peut donc des métiers sur
lequel on a eu des situations d'image
déficit d'image alors certains métiers
du bâtiment sur lesquels on est en
difficultés de recrutement même si les
emplois peu qualifiés
on va retrouver certains métiers de la
cuisine la salle notamment sur les
métiers qui s'attirent relativement peu
ou trois raisons que je viens d'évoquer
dominique degryse pour ces secteurs qui
peine à recruter et auquel l'organisme
public tente de pallier en organisant
par exemple des job dating que nous
couvrons régulièrement dans des centres
commerciaux comme l espace saint quentin
ce qui permet une meilleure visibilité
et un contact direct avec le demandeur
et le recruteur qu'on vend en images
c'est à l'espace saint quentin le mois
dernier à l'occasion du mois du commerce
pôle emploi encourage aussi
l'apprentissage oui et la formation en
interne comme l'expliquent rénale de
rafic et directeur de l' agence de pôle
emploi à guyancourt
il a des moyens aujourd'hui pôle emploi
est incapable de déployer donc son appel
l'action de formation préalable à
l'embauché ou la préparation
opérationnelle en europe en fonction du
type de contrat qui permet à l'employeur
de mettre en place une formation soit
avec un centre de formation est très
soit avec son propre centre de formation
ses expériences dans les grandes
surfaces sont leurs propres centres de
formation ce qui permet à l'employeur de
pouvoir avoir un salarié qui correspond
au profil recherché et l' agence de
guyancourt 1 qui compte 4000 400
demandeurs d'emploi de catégorie a sont
toujours nous ces catégories les
personnes qui n'ont pas travaillé le
mois précédent 70 % des chômeurs
inscrits dans cette agence ont le niveau
bac voire plus donc ce qui possible
poser un problème au niveau du
recrutement parce que parfois donc en
emploi en demande
un niveau peut-être inférieur au bac et
donc c'est un petit peu difficile de se
faire se rencontrer la demande et puis
l'offre la chronique à cause se poursuit
et des commerçants en colère à présent
oui alors on va rester dans le monde de
l'entreprise et puis du commerce avec
cette fronde des commerçants de montigné
de voisins et puis plus globalement de
l'agglomération suite à de très forte
augmentation de la cotisation foncière
des entreprises qui remplace la taxe
professionnelle elle est laissée
aujourd'hui à l'appréciation des
collectivités territoriales ils ont
lancé une pétition
on fait le point avec ce reportage suite
à la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle c'est aux collectivités
territoriales qu'il revient de fixer le
taux de la cotisation foncière des
entreprises
celui déterminé par la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines en 2012 a fait l'effet d'une
bombe auprès de la plupart des
entreprises du territoire
elles ont vu leurs cotisations augmenter
parfois jusqu'à 900 %
c'est l'ancien le l'ancienne taxe
professionnelle qui a été été annulée
par par sarkozy et qui a été repris par
les par les régions par les régions et
communautés d'agglomération sur toute la
france et qui avaient qui avait le champ
libre pour faire le pour faire à nouveau
calcul je suis passé de 280 3 599 euros
ce n'est pas du tout le reflet donc des
évolutions de mes revenus
un 5,8 ça se saurait si on avait des
revenus qui pouvaient être multipliée de
cette manière là en 2011 de 260 euros
de mémoire ou 360 euros et lâche pas sa
1588 euros commerçants et entreprises
sont mobilisés comme au centre dumas né
à montigny où circule une pétition à
l'attention de monsieur le maire
pour l'instant elle a recueilli une
cinquantaine de signatures ces gens de
la communauté d'agglomération ne se rend
pas compte qu'un chiffre d'affaires
n'est pas un résultat
il faudrait qu'ils descendent un petit
peu dans les entreprises pour savoir ce
qu'elle est la différence entre les deux
les maires des trois communes de droite
voisin montigné l'encours se sont réunis
mardi dernier et devrait faire parvenir
prochainement un communiqué ce jeudi
soir le conseil syndical de
l'agglomération se réunit à l'ordre du
jour le débat d'orientation budgétaire
cette question devrait être abordée
invité sur notre plateau cette semaine
le président de la communauté
on n'a pas fermé la porte aux
négociations je proposerai mois une
délibération au conseil du 20 décembre
et au bureau de cette semaine des élus
en fonction de ce que la loi sera
modifiée
ce que le mystère nous pourra nous
permettre d'alléger
nous voilà donc il y aura des
ajustements dès cette année ont tous
comme tout ce que le gouvernement et
tous que la loisne père l'adresse bien
sûr le fera pour effectivement on
essayait d'éviter ces ces inégalités
c'est l'injustice que cette loi ou fait
porter un particulier aux entreprises
étaient donc sur le plateau du 7-8 cette
intervention du président de la
communauté d'agglomération tout début de
semaine tout autre sujet à présent dans
cette page économie la recherche
spatiale
ah oui le département compte de grands
groupes industriels spécialisés dans ce
domaine ce qui contribue aussi à son
dynamisme économique nous avons
rencontré le directeur d'astrium filiale
spatiale de eads
installée aux mureaux le site vient de
fêter ses 100 ans une game on nous parle
de son histoire
l'établissement existe depuis 1912 et
nous avons effectué des activités
aéronautiques et maintenant spatiale
depuis depuis plusieurs décennies et
donc l'importance de notre proxim de
notre localisation
elle tient à la proximité des moyens de
locomotion est également de
l'environnement industriel nous avons
anneaux
fournisseur important partenaire
important pas très loin à vernon qui est
la sté cma mais également un tissu
indice feng d'entreprise avec lequel
nous travaillons en partenariat sur
l'ensemble du département et de la
région ile de france et cette
localisation dans les yvelines et
stratégique d'une part par la scène qui
est vraiment derrière l'entreprise et
qui permet l'acheminement notamment de
morceaux de la fusée ariane qui sont
ensuite acheminés à kourou pour pouvoir
envoyer des satellites sur orbite
hugues aimons explique l'importance
stratégique justement d'être situé dans
le département près de la scène en
l'écoutant on contribue également au
développement bad et collabore pas des
collaborateurs mais des jeunes qui sont
issus des mureaux est ce que nous
faisons surtout c'est que nous et nous
étions les aider à à ce que les leurs
études se réalise au mieux donc on
participe à des bourses d'études et à la
sélection d'un certain nombre de ces
jeunes à travers justement ces
financements et on est également je
dirais à même de travailler avec les pme
de la région et notamment sur
l'amélioration de ces pme on a un projet
qu'on a menées depuis maintenant 2 2010
et qui aboutit à l'été 2012
c'est un projet qui s'appelle comète sur
un certain nombre de pme pilote il y
avait cette pme pilote si je me souviens
bien et nous avons amené ces pme a
évolué en même temps que nous sur les
mêmes technologies et les mène
on leur a apporté des méthodes de
qualité sur lequel on a travaillé
ensemble de façon à ce que tous ensemble
on progresse dans le même sens et donc
c'est un projet commun avec certaines
pme qui sont des sous traitants
de notre entreprise hugues aimons parler
des jeunes des mureaux qui pourront
peut-être plus tard étudié à l'estaca
cette école d'ingénieurs spécialisée
dans les transports qui va s'installer
en 2015 à montigny le bretonneux
on écoute sa directrice qui nous
explique pourquoi l'école va déménager
de paris continue les critères qui ont
qui ont joué pour nous ça a été à la
fois le le tissu économique local
c'est-à-dire le fait d'avoir à proximité
des entreprises un écosystème
industrielle qui soit proche de notre
coeur de formation c'est à dire des
entreprises dans le domaine des
transports et des sites de r&d
donc il y avait cet élément là il ya
aussi le fait de pouvoir offrir à nos
étudiants un campus un environnement
académique à
d'autres étudiants l'accès à des
ressources académiques variés qu'ils
soient riches
l'estac a un qui devrait s'installer à
montigny en 2015 juste à côté de la gare
en fait donc ça va avec cette rénovation
finalement du quartier avec le vélodrome
open du like c'est aussi la multiple la
multitude des entreprises aérospatiales
présente dans le territoire qui a motivé
ce choix ces entreprises avec lesquelles
on travaille dans le cadre de la
formation qui interviennent dans le
cadre de notre formation puisque notre
formation alors il ya une spécialisation
spatiale qui commence à partir de la
quatrième année 4e et 5e années et eads
fait partie des entreprises qui
concourent à la formation travaille avec
le cnes son travail est l'une des rares
on a un certain nombre de partenariats
forts qui permettent que nos étudiants
et
voilà accès à
véritablement ou savoir-faire du spatial
français
quelques infos en plus à présent pour
poursuivre cette chronique échos oui
alors on commence avec les élections au
sein des tpe les très petites
entreprises sont celles de moins de onze
salariés qui représentent 4 millions et
demi de français
c'est le moment de voter pour vos
représentants syndicaux pour ce faire
c'est très simple par internet ou voie
postale toutes les informations sont à
retrouver sur le site internet élections
tpe point travail.gouv.fr et sachez que
la dette de faim de vote a été étendu
jusqu'au 17 décembre steen demande de la
cgt qui vient d'être accepté donc donc
voilà vous avez jusqu'au 17 décembre
pour voter en ligne
nous parlons maintenant du lancement du
deuxième groupe réseau plato saint
quentin en yvelines
oui alors les réseaux plato et ont été
mis en place par la chambre de commerce
1 depuis de nombreuses années elle
touche maintenant ces réseaux concerne
maintenant les commerçants un premier
groupe a été lancée on voit sur ces
images il y a deux mois l'idée en fait
c'est de rassembler une vingtaine de
commerçants qui vont être coachés par
des grands chefs d'entreprise pour
connaître un petit peu d'aidé technique
pour ben voilà augmenter son réseau et
puis augmenter aussi son chiffre
d'affaires donc au moment où on parle le
deuxième groupe réseau pour les
commerçants est en train d'être lancée
la star academy vous le savez neuvième
édition ce soir on en parlait au début
de cette émission de cette édition avec
les présentateurs une interview vous
avez suivi les coulisses durant toute
cette semaine puisque c'est à chaque
taux fort que se trouve le centre
névralgique de cette nouvelle édition
qui sera diffusée sur nrj 12 dès ce soir
est une entreprise yvelinoise est
associée à la star academy cette année
et oui tout à fait c'est l'entreprise
générique un spécialisé dans les soins
capillaires qui a été créé en 2005 par
un ancien cadre de l'oréal nous vous en
dirons plus rapidement et nous irons
revoir ce chef d'entreprise que nous
avions rencontrée au moment du lancement
de son entreprise
on termine par la jambe à eco forcément
à présent oui alors deux événements le
premier à la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de versailles qui organise
une réunion
alors c'est sûr la fiscalité directe des
entreprises dans un contexte rang des
transnationales ça peut paraître un
petit peu compliqué l'idée c'est de
mieux comprendre les enjeux fiscaux
quand on veut exporter notamment en
europe donc c'est lundi 10 décembre de
13h45 à 16h30 c'est gratuit et c'est à
la chambre de commerce
paris à versailles pardon avenue de
paris voilà et puis un deuxième rendez
vous à la cité des métiers de saint
quentin en yvelines basée à trappes
vous pourrez participer toujours
gratuitement à une réunion d'information
sur la formation en apprentissage
mardi 11 décembre à 14h et
l'apprentissage et l'insertion
professionnelle ce seront les sujets de
la chronique échos de la semaine
prochaine la chronique échos donc ce
sera au même horaire ce sera la semaine
prochaine jeudi prochain merci à l'iss
et puis je rappelle également que fit
l'écho le magazine économique de la
rédaction le bimensuel sortira vendredi
nous irons au laboratoire national
d'essai qui est installé attrapé kit
esse notamment les jouets de noël
merci à lisandro un stand et passionné
de reptiles ont lancé une radio sur le
web
auparavant nous allons prendre de la
hauteur avec une compétition de
cerfs-volants 7 à plaisir une mon chat
régionales il y a quelques jours
catherine de la tow in audi - ils
veulent parfaitement en ligne
un vrai ballet flottant compétition
régionale de serre volante ce dimanche
qualificative pour les championnats de
france en 2013
depuis le parc des quatre saisons à
plaisir plusieurs manches disputées en
individuel en perd ou par équipe chaque
fois la même règle réalisé trois figures
imposées
des figures choisi chaque début d'année
par les instances internationales est
évalué sur le terrain par des juges
les figures bon les connaît par coeur à
nous d'y réaliser le mieux possible dans
une échelle il est né chez elle par la
fenêtre devant et il faut le faire comme
il faut et après le ballet ça va entre
deux et quatre minutes se ravaler
musicale je dirais ça s'approche impôts
de
nouba dernières techniques par exemple
jugeant leur art une boucle il regarde
si la figure et l'exécuter si les angles
sont bien faits si la vitesse est
toujours la même et sur respecte ma
prière d'échelle
deux clubs de plaisir et l'organisateur
de la manifestation un club bien armée
qui compte des adhérents placé entre les
5e et 10e place au niveau national ainsi
qu'une équipe vice-championne d'europe
à les voir évoluer dans le ciel bleu
plaisir wa tout paraît si simple si on
sait faire du vélo sur le cerf-volant
c'est le même principe vous imagine
examen guidon dans les mains pour aller
à gauche en vo on va pousser à gauche à
droite tueur a tiré à gauche comme à
droite et inversement point la droite
le cerf-volant c'est pareil il suffit
juste de savoir sa pâle avoir peur
prendre son temps rester calme merci
vincent paillart est un compétiteur mais
également un initiateur il donne des
cours en une après-midi de pratique il
est possible selon lui de savoir faire
décoller son cerf-volant et de démarrer
des évolutions mais pour une maîtrise
totale
il faudra tout de même compter plusieurs
heures d'entraînement